we got an early look at the closed beta
for back for blood which is kicking off
this weekend for those of you with early
access
but for those of you who don't have
early access why not check out this
gameplay of one of the games as of yet
unseen campaigns blue dog hollow if you
enjoy the video
why not give us a like and sub it helps
more than you think and it means you
want to see
more back for blood coverage from us and
remember if you didn't get access to
this weekend's beta it is open to
everybody on
august 12th
another day another dice with death
so what are you hoping to find out here
often my father might be out here
bad news he may be but he's the only
family i've got left
takes more than blood to be a family
need to reload
need to find another way
no way through
cutting cross country will save you time
on foot
here's hoping you can drive back with
belisaro and the rest of his team
what
but maybe your bullets will follow
cool
running dry here
[Music]
weapons here
we went from everything to nothing so
fast
spilt milk honey spilled milk any heavy
hitter fans
personally the recoil chafes
i don't see anyone's name on it
could come in handy see that
hey dickwads watch where you're shooting
i am
so sorry
huh
[Music]
entering the premises
firecrackers here
over there
it's your lucky day hr
that doesn't look right
uh
what's that point the business end
at the ridden please
well that's an eyesore by no mistake
yeah that's a definite
nope
first aid cabinet over there
elmo
well what do you know
they are here
let's see what's in here
i know oh did that hurt
[Music]
huh
here take my hand
thanks honey
that's going to make the bloody mess
reloading
oh
right
warm up
let's do this
[Music]
reloading
i need to be more careful
you bloody shot me
going in
sniper rifle this could be the
difference
it always amazes me what you can find in
someone's vehicle
instead of drive reloading
you're welcome but would you mind did it
turn that door closed susceptible
my husband ben hasn't been feeling right
so get what you need and be on your way
they told us it would probably clear up
by itself but
we should head down to that place they
set up at the fairgrounds anyways
we're not really ones for company if you
get my drift
thanks for buying
good
move out people
[Music]
reloaded
checking the vehicle
pipe bomb here
anyone got ammo
cocktail over here you didn't have basic
training didn't you walker
trying to get yourself killed
nearly out
oh
smg
i don't here what i might need this
nothing to worry about
i'm all right sir accidents happen
well there's something you don't see
every day putting dry here
ah the night sky a universe of mysteries
what wonders and truth to that boy
what terrors knock it off with the alien
[ __ ]
we got enough trouble down here on earth
we've been receiving reports of
something strange in your area how could
you not be open to the possibility of
alien life
especially after what we've seen
i'm surprised you didn't run off in
storm area 51 when all this started
the area 51 myth was started by the
government
to take people's attention off what they
were doing in areas one to fifty
checking the card
this way
always loved a stroll in the woods
reminds me of my teens
minus johnny mayberry in a purloined
bottle of my paws
best hooch to loosen that boy's
inhibitions
ain't nothing like a preacher's son
unwound if you know what i'm
saying
[ __ ] your fire sorry
there's an old church up ahead you
should be able to rest up there
be careful britain may not be your only
threat place is falling apart
so you'll have to secure it before
you're bunked up
sniper rifle
let me know if you see any meds
reloading
this looks promising
what's your line of sight i'm surrounded
uh
oh sweet sanctuary you bloody shocked me
appreciate it
hot damn that stings
ah
there we go hon
thanks mom
whatnot
could come in here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
first aid captain always best to be your
best
[Applause]
[Music]
finally
[Music]
you